well eight news now is tackling the food
insecurity problem right here in the
valley and the issue is concerning the
grim reality is that one in nine
nevadans don't know where their next
meal is coming from according to one
grocery store well today they are
weighing in on ways to help
it's hard to think that hunger is
happening right in our backyards and the
contradiction is 40 percent of food that
we produce in the united states goes to
waste a briana martindale with smith's
groceries says the hunger problem in
nevada is alarming for children the
numbers are worse if we dig even deeper
one in six
children in the state of nevada don't
know where their next meal is coming
from one solution martindale says is
rethinking those expiration dates we see
on each food item we purchase
she says expiration dates are not
regulated and that can cause many items
to get tossed in the trash it doesn't
mean that that food is bad that is just
the debt the date set forth by that
vendor saying this may be the best
use by date for peak quality and peak
taste some options experts say you
should consider take those items with
near expiration dates and freeze them
also if your fresh produce have a
blemish peel the skin and get creative
with recipes
smith's groceries is joining the fight
with their zero hunger zero waste policy
an effort to eliminate food waste in the
company by 2025. you grab an apple and
it has a blemish on it what we will do
is mark that produce down we put a few
items in what we call a red bag and put
on a red bag rack if it doesn't get sold
we donate it to the food bank like three
square
well we will have more about this issue
that's impacting so many around the
valley coming up on our 8 news now
special which airs on august 27th we
hope you can join us